et le fil rouge de la journée rumeurs de
fusions acquisitions et de rachat même
rachat d'alstom par l'américain general
electric
est ce que le ministre de l'économie
doit aller installer un détecteur de
mensonges dans son bureau il était
nécessaire d'y voir clair
[Musique]
pour la première fois notre chaîne a été
capable de jouer aussi d'une certaine
manière un rôle de contrôle sur ce qui
se passait au sein des décisions en
matière de politique industrielle
et c'est ça qui est formidable
[Musique]
sept cent mille personnes ont vu ce
documentaire sur la chaîne parlementaire
ce qui est un considérable
dans le documentaire ce qui est
explosive c'est qu'en fait ça remet à
plat cette fameuse ventes d'alstom à
general electric un fleuron industriel
français qui va passer sous bannière
américaine quel est l'état qui
accepteraient classe prévue de quatre
vingt quinze mille salariés dix-huit
mille en france soit vendue à la découpe
en 72 heures dans le dos du gouvernement
ces documentaires une et c'est sa force
en réalité on rend pas la problématique
française et puis finalement en
déroulant le fil on se rend compte que
en arrière-plan le sujet est encore plus
important que ça le sujet c'est quoi
c'est la lutte économique que nous
livrent les états unis en 2010 la
justice américaine lance une vaste
enquête sur alstom
elles soupçonnent l'entreprise française
d'utiliser la corruption depuis plus de
dix ans pour remporter des contrats dans
de nombreux pays et c'est ça qu'il faut
évidemment ce documentaire c'est qu'en
réalité on se rend compte très vite que
oui à une polémique sur le plan français
oui et des arbitrages sans doute
discutable aux yeux des uns et des
autres mais qu'en réalité tout ça nous
échappe un tout petit peu de lait pas me
dire que comme ce par hasard au même
moment il y avait le département la
justice car était d'abord un gars
monsieur karoutchi pour bien montrer que
ça rigole pas et dans le même temps
comme par hasard gerald trick qui arrive
qui dit je vous aime et je veux vous
racheter et qu'à la suite de cette
opération sera électrique est leader
mondial
il faut pas des bisounours deux mois
après la diffusion de ce documentaire
olivier marc l'ex député les
républicains déclenché cette commission
denquête après m'avoir vu même
personnellement il m'a demandé des
contacts notamment les contacts des deux
journalistes qui ont réalisé ce
documentaire est
ça a été un élément déterminant de sa
commission denquête ça c'est une voie là
c'est une véritable fierté qu'on arrive
à faire ça dans le cadre d'une émission
comme comme des badoc là c'est une vraie
réussite c'est une vraie réussite pour
cette émission et c'est une vraie
réussite pour la chaîne